we had the kids mullet championships
happened this weekend we had a lot of
people posting about this with you theo
all right i kind of want to look through
some of these guys if you want since
bobby stole my style a while back
um so we'll scan through some i know who
won but we'll scan through something
well can we judge or who won yeah yeah
all right
so i'll go start here hell yeah dude all
right this one's good dude
i think brock is coming in hot here i
think it's kind of a basic kind of
thicker white look at the side dude
three lines that fisherman's son look
look at the four lines on the side what
does that mean
i don't know but it's like if he did
that himself he's talented
i'm sure his mother did it oh here we go
oh callan uh he's got some accusations
against him but bro great guy though
also his hair's receding at that age
dude i don't know bro look which makes
it even more likely that this is brian
cowan
um yeah no i think that he's a beautiful
kid though oh here we go dude
i would dude that's my son i would love
that would you want that oh
dude that'd be great i would lift this
kid up i'd throw him so [ __ ] high in
the air he'd never come down or i just
give him tasks like go get the squirrels
yeah i mean okay tapa yeah right and
you'll go bring like three or four
squirrels we'll boil them yeah yeah dude
i love oh oh catching now this dude
definitely you could tell he'll [ __ ]
he's got something in him yeah he's got
something in him dude you know he's
young but i bet hold on hold on man yeah
let's go back to [ __ ] jesus christ
he's like you could see in his eyes look
at him yeah
he [ __ ] means business and when he
gets older straight teeth oh he looks
like he took some of his teeth out just
because he wanted to
he is a gangster boy let's see somebody
else he's out of lawton
oh [ __ ] okay jewish guy showing up out
of hogansburg new york do you think he's
jewish dude 100
italian i would say actually i think he
you know who he looks like is the guy
man my brain's been so bad no you know i
know what you know to me you know what
she he looks like
uh what's that woman that was like oh
like she did them she was a madame for
the prostitutes uh oh elaine maxwell no
flies no heidi flight heidi flies wow
heidi flicks that looks like a young
heidi flies ooh i like that i like that
yeah yeah um
wait wait look it up honey see
heidi flies yeah he does have body flies
vibes yeah heidi flies vibes um and also
he looks like uh who is the famous
podcaster that we've all been on his
show
adam
corolla on the left it looks like adam
crawford i don't know corolla dude yeah
why can't he's mexicans in that [ __ ]
photo does he i don't think adam likes
mexicans
i don't really yeah
i want to be mexican go on
please brother
oh emmett oh oliver tree
oh yeah a young oliver tree dude he took
that straight out of that oak tree yeah
dude what's up ollie dude oh town or oh
tree pick one
what oh town oh town bro i don't know
what that [ __ ] means the band oh town
i never heard of it
all right bring up the next one m is
good though emmett's good
out of carthage huh
tim dillon dude oh yeah a baby tim
dillon oh this dude will suck start a
skateboard right here this little buddy
yeah out of mining wisconsin boy he's
gonna turn out to be a promoter
yeah like brian monarch oh he's gonna
promote a damn honey bun into his pocket
i bet if he's smart i like it good luck
emmitt
epic epic dude
what a cool name too
out of la joya texas yeah now this
almost seems i worry epic might be one
of those kids because it's that he goes
on to really live this lifestyle he gets
a motorbike next year right it gets
intense and he just you know it's a lot
of pressure and he could end up on drugs
yeah good luck bud good luck epic all
right let's see two more and then we'll
pick a winner here yeah oh oh
look at the tongue dude jack is cute
don't look at the tongue dude that's
weird yeah yeah
yeah yeah i wasn't the photographer i
was like can you do one without tongue
i mean you're a kid why did the
photographer go we'll choose another one
you know what i mean
yeah okay yeah let's move on let's move
on dude just to stay legit over here
oh wow
and he almost looks honestly like he
doesn't want to be doing this yeah like
he was forced to get the haircut yup
yeah so i'm going to vote no one jameson
is because they did this to him
yeah he won't even look at the can't you
can tell
or maybe it's like the second photo
could be like why'd you take the
sunglasses off me oh
a little bit but look at the mouth on
the first one and i'm not looking i
don't look at the mouth never mind move
along
yeah that [ __ ] is bad dude oh this guy's
like [ __ ] 40. yeah
you can't have a 40 year old in there
dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah unless dude we all we all know this
guy's scottish and not american yeah
yeah this dude is definitely looks like
one that's william wallace bro
this guy that's [ __ ] straight up
braveheart dude
this guy looks like one of the uh
characters in the newsies let's keep it
moving yeah yeah let's keep it moving
this dude will sell you some [ __ ]
land in his bedroom bro
you know
yeah yeah yeah
i'm out on lincoln yeah he seems like he
took it in the sun too this almost seems
like he's not things aren't going to
work out well
latino huh you think it's latino my son
i don't know dude
really fremont yeah this dude definitely
has had i wouldn't just tug the back of
that he knows somebody that's picked a
damn strawberry i'll tell you that bro
beautiful guy mason actually looks like
my mother a little bit beautiful onward
how many are these getting through
there's more i could tell
there's more i can tell you the winner
if you want you wanna know the winner uh
bring up my favorite one emmett the
other emmett
oh no the other what was the other one
parkinson's or whatever his name is
what's his name we have rustin emmett
and bailey rustin
bring up the little guy like the first
one i told you if you don't mind
uh right there in the middle on the
bottom rustin nope right there
bam that's a good one dude
this little we never even saw that one
this tater hunter right here little
rustin yeah that's a good one from
pocahontas arkansas yeah look at him
doing work right there he's already
working dude i love it changing a tire
dude on his house that looks like a meth
lab
all right who do you think won
i dude i i mean um
i'm gonna go with the oliver tree hair
wow with the [ __ ] cut
bowl cut i like that that is a very
country cut too you can tell that his
mother did that cut go in on that it's
emmett on the second row in the middle
zoom in on him
it's clean
yeah it's clean and dirty at the same
time you can tell somebody did that at
his house with scissors i've had that
cut yeah yeah that's a good cut that
bangs the bangs you can tell i'm gonna
go go back out
i'm gonna go with my boy uh
uh
i'm gonna roll with
i kind of like
little jack
oh that's cute yeah he's cute dude why
you picked the phone with the with the
tongue bro i just wanted to make it up
to him by being nice i just feel like i
don't know what's going on all right
okay what happened brother so was the
champion this year
champion was
emmett
damn
dude johnson
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you